hi everyone I'm Brady I'm the person who
makes the films on periodic videos and
believe it or not this is our 300th
upload so first of all thank you to
everyone who's been watching the videos
commenting and subscribing it's all your
involvement that has really made this
worthwhile
and speaking of viewer involvement by
popular demand it's finally time for us
to make some videos in which the
scientists answer your questions so if
there's something you want anyone in the
team to answer please let us know you
can get in touch by email there's the
address periodic videos at gmail.com or
Twitter or Facebook or of course leave a
message here on the YouTube video now I
want some of the questions to be a
surprise so I'm not going to show all
the comments under the video if yours
doesn't appear don't worry I have seen
it I'm just keeping a bit of a secret
another thing we're trying to do this
year is collect photos of all the people
who watch the video is sort of a montage
of all the viewers so if you're fancy
sending us one we'd prefer it to sort of
show you and the computer something like
this obviously watching periodic videos
or our YouTube channel and also you can
send that to us by the email that's
periodic videos at gmail.com and we'll
randomly choose a few of them to give
prizes in typical style they probably
won't be prizes worth a lot of money but
they'll be something a bit different
also while I have your attention I'd
love to tell you about my new channel
which is called backstage science
there's a lot of videos starting to go
on it now basically it's going behind
the scenes and some of Britain's biggest
and best science facilities I've been
looking at lasers synchrotrons
Neutron sources even a few spacecraft
and there's a lot more to come it's well
worth a look so please check it out and
if you like it maybe you could subscribe
but that's all from me I really look
forward to all your questions which I'll
soon be asking to all the periodic
videos team thanks a lot and again thank
you for watching catch you later